a family disturbance on the west side of
the valley ends in a deadly shooting it
happened last night on
spurt court that's near alta and buffalo
joe muller spoke to neighbors and has
this reaction
police say it appears the son in this
incident was acting in self-defense when
he allegedly shot and killed his father
now the shooting happened here
on spur court this all started around
six last night police say the father
involved attacked the son
and took off when police got here they
spoke with people in the house but could
not find the father
hours later around 10 30 metro got
another call after shots rang out they
say the father returned home
the son had shot the father the shooters
surrendered two officers and was
questioned
neighbors say they can't imagine an
argument leading to this hard to believe
my family is very close and we don't
argue so
hear people arguing like that and
getting to that point it's just
sad a few neighbors say they heard
several gunshots last night but
everyone was surprised when they heard
about what exactly happened
police did not say what the argument was
about the shooter is not in custody
police tell me since this is a
self-defense
case they do not expect charges to be
filed but the case was submitted to the
district attorney's office
for them to make the final decision
reporting near alton buffalo joe mohler
8 news now